[Music]
hi Singapore thank you so I know it's
the evening I know you guys saw that at
4:30 the bar opens and I know you guys
are like ready like one more talk later
that I will have that cocktail but I
hope you find this useful and I'm pretty
sure you will if you work on the web how
many people here use the web give me a
show of hands right everybody does and
that's why we're here
because no matter what JavaScript PHP
Ruby whatever you use even if you use
like cobalt oh right right you everybody
uses Internet and I'm gonna tell you a
little bit about me and I'll tell you
about my use case which might surprise
you
so I work for Baker Hughes now you see
GE over there and we'll be surprised
Baker uses the oil and gas division of
GE oil and gas so that that little
gasoline that you put into your Waker
right it's extracted from the earth and
do you know what I do on a day-to-day
basis I write code to make sure that oil
is extracted from the earth efficiently
now you might be terrified to think oh
javascript controls oil extraction
don't worry it does not it only manages
the visualization of data we made sure
you know we have quality control come on
people so but my point is the web is
everywhere think of any use case any
single part of your life
the web is there and somebody has a
website about it somewhere right so
let's talk about our users where do your
users come from so if you use the
Internet and I'm hoping everybody here
has some part in creating the Internet
you write it or you create content on
the internet because you want people to
consume it right am i right yes
so if you want users to consume it where
your users come from
so I was breaking it down and these are
the three highest users around the world
and now we are China and I tried to find
statistics but none of that is valid
because of reason so I'm gonna skip that
and I'm gonna focus on India where I'm
from where I get access to easier
statistics and I'm gonna compare that
with the next largest country per users
which is the USA and I'm going to show
you a gap right so in India we have 1300
million that's 1.3 billion people and
out of that only 45% of India is
connected to the Internet
right so 45% of 1.3 billion people is
nearly 627 million users and that's
considering the people who use internet
right now let's say look at the USA the
USA has almost 85% connected oh I think
the mic started working only now my bad
and so by the initial the start of how
many users are there we start to see the
gap now this is just a rough draft of
how many the percentage of Internet
penetration so when we say Internet
penetration that's like how many people
use the internet frequently enough to
make a dent on the user percentages and
you can see the the places with the
largest number of people when they come
to South Asia or southern Africa right
that's the places with the lowest
penetration of Internet
and let me say lower penetration the
Internet is not going away
that means the lower that number is the
higher is the opportunity for you and
your product to go into those markets
right so if you see that's the
opportunity of people who are I've never
used the internet before and have an
idea or an interest in using the
Internet that's where in the future your
product will be used so how can we make
products that are targeted to those
people right and you see the higher
demographic so you see Canada at 87%
that means a lot of people have seen
what the Internet is like right if they
have any idea of the Internet and
they're happy with the tools that they
already use
but the products they already use what
is the chance that they lose your
product unless yours is a very
well-established product right so you
have competition which is more available
so let's look at these markets so the
market saturation of technical products
and this is what I was talking about in
the first world and when I say the first
world I want you to think of places like
Silicon Valley right that's where the
first Google came out of the first
Facebook came out of you know that's
where you think that technology started
from there right and when you come to
India or when you come to South Asia
right Facebook started in the Silicon
Valley and now the highest user base
oopsy-daisy don't mind me
the largest user base is now India so I
read a very interesting statistic that
Facebook right now has in 2016 I believe
it had about 200 million users in the US
and India overtook it in 2016 with 400
million and that was still only when
there was 35 percent of India
connected to the Internet imagine what
that number would be like if 70 percent
of India connected you know can you
imagine that amount of data that
Facebook can collect because that's what
Facebook is thinking about I think so my
goal is to help you think about the
larger picture you know to find out a
great balance in between performance
accessibility and user experience the
big three when it comes to how a person
decides to use your product now first
come will be performance but I'll show
you how performance can actually be it
actually can be helped with
accessibility and user experience you
don't have to compromise between the
three so the first and the easiest
barrier sometimes I feel is
internationalization and I'd like to
bring an example where I checked and I
can't really find that example here but
a very
an example internationally this is a
very common company right
uber is dominant across the world and
you would think that uber would care a
little bit more about one of their
largest consumer bases because the last
time I checked we were still there is
local grown competition against uber but
India is one of the largest markets for
uber now can you tell me if something
looks wrong in this picture and I and I
highlighted it for your ease
unfortunately my my laser pointer was
not working so what I'd like to point
out over here is that if you see
Lithuania right and I'm not dumping on
the thwe near here but I think India is
slightly larger number of people and a
lot more languages are supported in
Lithuania than in India or in countries
in in southern Africa which is not good
you know those are large countries with
a diverse population with a lot of
people who don't speak English right so
you want those companies who have large
user groups in those areas to cater to
communities in their own language
imagine you're somebody who's not
technically abled in your family in my
case that's my grandfather
you know the first time my grandfather
heard about uber he's like what is this
mover why should I trust some guy to
pick me up because he has never seen the
internet before you know so when when my
brother went to a different city and he
my grandfather wanted to go there
I'm sure you've all heard of Bangalore
so / is very strong in Bangalore my
grandfather wanted to go visit my
brother in Bangalore and my brother said
it's very easy you just opened a bird
and then you can you'll be dropped right
in front of my apartment and what do you
know my grandfather could not figure out
over in the end he just waited in the
airport for to us and my brother had to
make the trip and if you know Bangalore
traffic you know he hated that truth so
if we were had worked they would have
got to market this is my key point so
for non-native speakers for non-native
English speaker
because if you have a larger market or
if you have users you know who if you
can change a slight tweak in your
product can help users I don't know why
it's not done so far but this is this
the latest statistic I took maybe three
months back from the uber blog so
enabling native languages it is very
important to improve access and it's not
just there are other parts of
accessibility of course but for having
the languages is a different kind of
accessibility that maybe you don't think
about as much and when it comes to Asia
we know there are different languages at
play and different people at play so I
feel like internationalization is just a
very easy barrier that you can cross to
make your products that much more
interesting for your users and this is
just adding it if you're curious about
how internationalization work it's very
easy you can just add the language code
and most of the time if you have those
characters in Unicode if they should
work and there might be cases where in
specific where a particular language
does not work that's outside of the
scope of my talk it's just this is just
a starting point for you if you are
interested in this so the next story is
is where I really want to focus on going
beyond an iPhone or handling real world
devices now I'm hoping this crowd will
be a bit different but I'm going to ask
how many people here does not have an
iPhone you know your phone is not an
iPhone nice nice so I did a version of
this talk in the USA and I was very
disappointed there were maybe two hands
because everybody else had an iPhone but
moving to India you know this is not the
case you know a at least the people in
and around Asia would know that the
Chinese manufacturing companies have
pretty much a great market over here you
know if you have a price range and in
India we're kind of price conscious if
you heard about us and if you can get
all the features of an iPhone one-tenth
the price of an iPhone from a Chinese
company like away you're gonna get
you are a phone and we are going to put
a sticker on top that has an Apple logo
in it and claim it's knife one that's
how we do it honestly I've seen that so
many times so three little devices now
this is just the phones in my family so
if my phone is not listed because I used
my phone to take a photograph but but I
own and oneplus which is again a Chinese
manufactured company my mother
she is a proud owner of an iPhone my
grandfather could not care less like he
was he was he has the second phone which
is a touchscreen simply because he
thought touchscreen was in but he
figured out that he could not handle
that screen and he went back to his old
phone anyway and my father again he
could not care less about his phone so
that so long as it works
you know the calling bug so basically
when you when you have the such kind of
devices and more and more people are
moving to a sort of standardization when
it comes to such devices you know there
are more people moving to an iPhone but
that the quantity of people or the
market of an iPhone is still very very
very small in Asia so but if you've ever
seen the kind of checks for the sizes of
screens that comes up right mostly there
is like a standard list which has a
bunch of Apple devices and maybe if
you're lucky a few Nexus or Google
pixels are supported but a long list of
other popular devices are not in the
list so you can create a kind of
experience on mobile but maybe it's not
supported for the device which is one of
the most frequent ones and I think
Xiaomi has one of the largest selling
phones was the company that sells the
most phones in India and I've never seen
a Xiaomi aspect ratio ever in Google
Chrome
in Google Chrome and you check how much
your screen can be adjusted so that is a
big part and if you have you know if you
are creating a product to be used in
phones
have to stress this enough you know
hardware is created on equal you know
forget the screen sizes you can also
have really bad RAM you know you have
really bad expectations of what a device
can do you know how much speed in which
your device can load how much the size
the width and all that is is so hardware
in general if you only gonna create it
for a few specific devices that again
creates a block for your uses you know
please don't do that please think of at
least the top five devices in the market
that you're going into which are being
sold and just test for them okay and the
best thing that you can do is to get a
bunch of bang up phones you know with
the screen cracked I'm sure a few of you
here have few screen cracked phones you
know check with those check and see how
well your website does in those and see
what are the results
you know performance wise and
accessibility wise check with unequal
devices yeah so if you have seen the
previous slide you've seen what my
grandfather's phone looks like now my
grandfather he owns a bunch of property
because he's the head of the household
and very very recently one of his
friends told him about this website
called Airbnb yeah and he wanted me to
load Airbnb in that second phone that
was a task yeah I I thought I could do
it but I found out I couldn't sir and
you would think that a company has well
established a unicorn like a B&B would
care a little bit more and I tried to
take a photo of that but it came up
really bad and I did not want to scar
your eyes with that that's why I did not
put that photo to it but let me tell you
it's just it's so surprising the way
things turn out you know so if you are
creating a product for mobile just check
it for the mobiles that are very popular
you know your your average best-selling
Xiaomi and oppa phones should be enough
they would do the trick but go the extra
mile right and
one more thing is I'd like to talk about
using JavaScript frameworks now all of
us know some cool JavaScript framework
or the other I'm pretty sure a lot of
you know about a JavaScript framework
that I've never heard of before I've
recently heard is roguelike there are
some JavaScript frameworks that last
less than a milk product it's probably
true so if you have a latest and the
greatest JavaScript framework that you
have to try out I again would like you
to go to the same rule build your
website in that JavaScript framework and
then see how much time it takes to load
on a crappy phone maybe it works well on
an iPhone but please do not let the
iPhone be your benchmark please run it
on something with less than 2 GB of RAM
and see how well your mobile website
performs on that phone because the
majority of users who use the Internet
are coming in from mobile this is
especially true if you run a website
that has video in it now from my
understanding and my research most users
who connect through mobile internet
especially in local languages
non-english languages they try to access
video so if you have a video loading
element try to make it as performant as
possible for the lower ram mobile phones
because that is where your demographic
is what would your demographic is trying
to access that's what they want the most
speed for and that is where you're
letting them down solo now if you have
great performance on mobile for video
excellent and I'm at the risk of
violating the code of conduct I tell you
a model that you should definitely be
following that spawn hub if you have
ever tried to use that in mobile in
Indians mobile data you would know what
I am talking about and some people are
laughing because I know you have tried
it you know because if you have ever
used that mobile website they know who
their audience is and that's a very
performant website on a really crappy 2g
data you should
and that leads into oh no the Wi-Fi the
third story that I would like to tell
you so if the definition of Wi-Fi in
India is 10 Mbps to 30 300 Mbps that's
the actual so you see that this slightly
a bit of a variation and this I actually
I was surprised that there was three in
my mind I thought book that would be one
but surprisingly it's three so I
instinctively I knew that no matter what
the definition for Wi-Fi was was still
pretty bad and you think about it we
have 1.3 billion people crammed into one
small location on the map you know so
definitely if you have Wi-Fi connection
your family is taking it your neighbors
are probably taking it and then the
neighbors below you are also taking it
so that's the reason why it's so slow
because so many people are trying to
access your 13.5 Mbps connection that's
the fact now add this with the previous
point about how again the phones are
small they don't have RAM and they can't
use your website now you realize why
your website performance is so important
you know because that's the kind of
scenario you are in so not only is the
device playing against you but
infrastructure in general right the
amount of network poles around your
location the amount of bandwidth
available for your users to use because
at the end of the day if your website
does not load you know then it's not
good now I've not already included it
here but I do have a very and I did not
include it here because I don't want
Microsoft suing me but if you ever try
to load LinkedIn in India in 2g you
should try it it's an experience where
after 30 seconds you give up and you're
like I don't need a resume I don't need
a job anymore
I'm not opening LinkedIn that's that's
what happens so so how does your website
perform in 3g 2g or in those h+ i don't
know if anybody here has gotten an h+
ever i get it time to time
these days less frequently thankfully
I'm from a part of India that's blessed
with more network connections but the
more you go to a rural area you're going
to see your s + and - geez so how does
your website perform in those lower
bandwidth so again if you use one of the
major browsers there's probably a
network throttling option for you to
check this I'm sure most of you do this
but I advise you to do that again
you know just cover your bases and make
sure that your product has a fallback so
uber which I mentioned earlier even
though the internationalisation is
pretty bad they have a an app called
uber light in India and that actually
works what they did is they took out the
map which actually choked down most of
the data in over so you can't see the
map where the little car goes around
Hulu you know you have to guess whether
car is divine it oh it's probably there
but it works you know it actually loads
in real time so what if the map does not
exist you know whoever works that's good
at h+ that's pretty good
you know so so test your website on
crappy phones with slow speeds if you if
you forget everything else from this
talk this is the most important sentence
for you today please test your website
on really crappy phones with really slow
speeds that's the only thing you have to
do to make sure that your product works
in Asia you know if that happens then
your product at least from a technical
standpoint you have covered your grounds
so how can I simplify my website now I
know what the problem is how do I fix it
minimum number of downloads on the first
click now this is basic performance
stuff you know the amount of libraries
videos images all that you download in
the first click that is a huge drag on
what the first paint or the what user
sees first so if you can minimize the
number of downloads excellent if you
know that click is coming up and you can
preload parts of it again excellent
the biggest garbage of video that comes
in you know what chokes in your data the
most in any website or in any
application is video if you can optimize
your video and images you know it's
nothing like it it's the best way to
make your product faster now if I don't
know if somebody has covered SVG again
over here but I'm pretty sure there's a
great talk by una Kravitz and the last
J's conversation about SVG which I
suggest everybody check out because if
you can use SVG's instead of your images
again a great part in optimizing your
websites and a little bit more about
user experience because I feel that's
one of the most important parts you know
at the end of the day no matter how well
built your product is you know how much
the engineering team likes it if your
user does not like your product and what
good is it you know at the end of the
day the product comes as what the user
likes it to be know how well we build it
is based on what marketing tells us that
what the users like right so let's make
marketing happy with a little bit bonus
point so this is something I like to add
and this is something of some from my
personal experience like I said my
grandfather was very adventurous and it
comes technology and this happened the
first time that he opened up his gmail
account now he was very worried that he
would not understand what Gmail is and
how to navigate it
but thankfully the gods of Google have
decided that a lot of people don't know
what Gmail is so they have a little bit
of a demo happening and there are a few
great applications which has this kind
of a demo feature and I really like it
and I'd like to stress that if you're
creating a product for the Asian market
you know for people who have never used
the internet before the demo is a pretty
good way to go you know because if you
are looking for an a group of people who
have never seen the Internet right so
imagine this there are people who'd see
the Save button we've never seen a
floppy disk before and they and they
identify a floppy disk as oh this is the
3d
another image of a save button you know
it's pretty much the same thing for for
our elders when they see the Internet
right so they have no reference point to
this they've never seen anything like
the internet before so when they see a
hamburger button for the first time for
example they don't know what to do with
it they don't know that just clicking it
would open up the menu right so if you
have a like a a small arrow pointing to
it telling you hey click this it opens
up the menu that's good for you users so
based on what the target demographic is
I would suggest that you at least have
at least from the first load or the
first time a user signs in you have like
a little demo mode showing them what
each of the things does and that really
helps and it helps to explain the major
moving parts of and one more thing I'd
like to add probably again a bonus point
is that there are people at least in
India where I come from there are people
who are illiterate right so they're
people even if you write it in their
native language they're not good at
reading right so if you can have icons
explain sorry if you can have icons or
some kind of drawings that explain what
it does without having to read it now
text is important in some cases but
having a good eye can makes its
difference too so I'd like to stress
that having that a little bit of a bonus
user experience wise showing people
where things are done it really helps
for the older generation or people who
are just not used to technology
so in summary or yes only five more
minutes left so in summary what are the
things that you have to do to make your
websites better for a new user group is
nationalisation of your website which
means supporting different languages
maybe the major languages of any market
or any demographic that you hoping to
attract optimize it for like
non-standard aspect non-standard
aspect ratios I'd like to stress upon
that eloquently in the resid test your
website on crappy phones with slow
speeds that's
and for slow speeds have fallbacks when
you have slow internet make sure your
app does something instead of breaking
into a small broken image you know I
could and that's it
that is me on the interwebs you can
probably find me somewhere around for
the next two days and I hope this has
been useful Thank You Singapore